Bởi vì đang theo dõi bản thình sự bà khởi tiếp của bão nhân dân, thực của việc.
Só chữ tác động của hoàn lưu phía bác cơn bảo xung năm kết hợp với tác động của dơ bác xảy khu tụi nhật lời có chút qua chung bộ.
Bãnh giường của hội trụ só lý đến mức năm gình mát nên trong ngày,
nãy ở khu bất bác bộ có mưa mưa vừa và giải sát có dông, khu bộ có nơi mưa tò.
Sìa ngờ khu bất chung dù và đồng bằng cổng như các tình là kai sơn là có mưa vừa mưa tò và dông,
khu bộ có nơi mưa tò. Mưa lần cũng tiêm anh mưa cơ cao sầy ra lụ quán sát lợd đất ở các tình vùng nối,
cây mưa hiểm chung người dân. Sau chình dù mây bác có mưa nơi nơi độ các nhất ngày hôm nay ở khu bất bác bộ chỉ rao lượng thứ hai miệp biển đến bà mi độ.
Bộ vực chung mộ các tình thành tư thành hóa trở bảo đến khoảng 9, trong ngày hôm nay thì vẫn có mưa mưa vừa và giải sát có dông,
cộng bộ có nơi mưa tò. Như độ các nhất chung ngày hôm nay ở khu bất này sau đậm thứ hai miệp biển bà miệp hi độ.
Cố vực phía đông các tình thư ra lai đến lâm đồng phổ biển nhường mây về chiều tối có mưa sà và dông sải sát
cộng bộ có nơi mưa tò. Như độ các nhất chung ngày hôm nay ở khu bất này từ bà mưa đến bà miệp bà độ.
Lối hôm nay, các nơi chung bộ và cá năng bộ thì chung ngày hôm nay trở nhiều mây, các nước có mưa vành nơi.
Như độ các nhất chung ngày ở khu bất cao mên chung bộ là thứ hai miệp sau đến hai miệp chiến độ. Con ở khu bất năm bộ là thứ 3 mưa đến bà miệp bà độ.
Lễn chương tối giới chữ tắc lợp của só mùa tây nâm nên trên cả hai khu bật có mưa sà và dông trong các dông cần đề phòng só dất mạnh.
Truyền sáng công tiên thử tiếp biển ở khu bật biển đặc khu hoang sát có mưa sà và dông dài sát trong mưa dông có khảnh năng sẻ ra lức sói và só dất mạnh cấp só cấp bệp.
Fím mắt só đông năng đến đông phía nâm só tây nâm đến tay ở mất cấp bốn đến cấp năng sống biển cao thứ hai đến bộ mệt.
Con tải khu bật biển đặc khu chung sà có mưa sà và dông dài sát trong mưa dông có khảnh năng sẻ ra lức sói.
Só tây năng ở mất cấp năng sìm phía tay có lúc cấp sà lất cấp bệp tảm biển đặc sống cao thứ hai đến bà mệt.
Và sau đây là sự bảo thứ tí trong bà ngày tải một số tình hành phố chiến cạnh nước.